and finally our Wiki man columnist Rory
southernland says in this week's
magazine that the office has a new
Overlord Rory is on the show now Rory
thank you for joining spectator TV you
write for this week's magazine about the
worrying rise of the office box ticker
who are these people and why are you
concerned about
it well what particularly concerns me is
there always seems to be this strange
phenomenon which is large
companies employ huge numbers of people
Rel relatively few of whom seem to be
principally engaged in effectively
performing the task for which the
company has been hired instead there's
this ever growing bureaucracy I think I
quot in my piece that the amount spent
on HR salaries uh since I think 2017 has
gone from 15 billion to 25 billion a
year and I think it's worth asking
what's going on and I think it comes
down to you know kind of well that old
Latin phrase you know quis custodiat
ipsos custodes and it's the people who
are engaged in effectively
quantifying um or optimizing the
efficiency of the organization never
really apply the same scrutiny to
themselves um and so that so that if
you're a call center worker which is you
know seen as a cost okay as far as the
business is concerned I don't think a
call center worker is a cost I think
it's part of the value a business
creates but it's defined as a cost by
the kind of people in the finance
function your work is scrutinized and
your productivity is obsessed over by
tons and tons of people who would regard
you know 10 minutes making a cup of tea
is you know wasted time meanwhile the
people effectively imposing this
scrutiny never seem to actually shrink
in their numbers they seem just
continuously to grow it's almost a
branch of corporate oncology if you like
and they're not really in fact their
productivity what we know what's the
productivity of your finance department
no one has a clue their productivity
doesn't seem to be scrutinized it
doesn't seem to be measured and weirdly
mysteriously as a proportion of overall
headcount these people never seem to do
anything except grow uh David Graber the
late Anthropologist actually wrote a
whole piece about this called
job
in which he theorized that contrary to
the usual kind of idealistic
explanations of private sector
businesses um uh jobs can exist
for all manner of reasons one of which I
think is you know the burden of
Regulation undoubtedly creates more and
more of these jobs uh the fact that you
send more and more people to University
who are somehow prepared to do a desk
job but regard being a plumber as
weirdly beneath them that undoubtedly
magnifies the availability of people for
these jobs but also in some cases I
think they're kind of there as a kind of
reputational uh Shoring up mechanism uh
for the Senior Management in the case of
HR who fear a scandal uh or a breach of
something more acutely than they care
about their customers in the short to
medium term that's one explanation uh in
the case of Finance You could argue that
the growth of things like you know the
spreadsheet as a technology has
effectively created this absurd culture
of over
measurement uh which has brought with it
a large number of people whose job is
effectively just effectively channeling
numbers through spreadsheets from one
person to another without any really
clear idea other than the just default
juristic that more information is better
more measurement is better more metrics
are better if you question that
assumption then it's perfectly plausible
that huge sedes of people are being
created and if they ultimately looked at
the uh their output uh it would be
effectively negative their contribution
to the effect effective running of the
company would almost certainly be
negative you say in your piece that you
think that the uh culture of box ticking
is actually part of the productivity
crisis that we have here in the UK now
some and a culture of measurement my a
culture of measurement now who those who
enjoy asking people to fill in the
documents to fill in the spreadsheets to
get to collect as many numbers as
possible might say well you know we're
we're trying to automate we're trying to
simplify we're trying to make sure all
the information is easily accessible and
in one place you're suggesting actually
you're creating some needless work a lot
of the time and and I think the the
really interesting thing about your
thesis is are your resources going to
the people who actually do what the
company's supposed to do provide the the
product that that the company wants to
provide or is it going to all the red
tape within the organization that
sometimes slows those things down well
put beautifully I'm a very eminent
academic I know said that um when he
first joined the history faculty at the
University of Cambridge the entire
faculty was run by as he described it a
middle-aged woman who knew everything
and he said he looks at The Faculty now
and there are more administrators than
there are
historians so those of us in our 50s
have seen this trend over our working
lives I think I think people who've come
in recently into the into the off into
office life or indeed into the public
sector where it's perhaps even more
acute haven't noticed this trend but
anybody in their 50s or above will have
seen since they started work in the 80s
and the 90s that this trend seems kind
of
inexorable are you measuring the right
things are you optimizing for the right
things and is a kind of um culture of
what you might call pseudo
efficiency where you're trying to
optimize the parts rather than
optimizing the hole is this actually
good um because I mean you know one of
the great lessons of w Edward steings
was if you want to optimize the hole you
have to sub optimize the
parts and yet what we have is we have
this culture of what you might call
pseudo efficiency that creeps into every
single pocket of corporate life or
indeed institutional life and it's
always directed at the people doing
useful work not at the bureaucracy
itself and my claim is that this has led
to a kind of sovietization of of
capitalism well let me ask you Rory uh
my last question to you is what would
your advice to workers who are under the
thumb of the Box ticking be how should
they rebel against the Box tickers well
my claim is that to some extent the
working from home phenomenon is an act
of Rebellion most people in knowledge
work aren't unionized they have no
capacity for collective bargaining but
they did discover that after the
pandemic it was quite difficult for an
employer to sack everybody
simultaneously and I one thing I would
argue for actually to a large extent is
that um campaigning for uh
liberalization of working hours and
practices and
locations is a sensible win-win if you
look at it in the right mindset okay
maybe people are 3% less productive if
they work from home as one statistic
showed okay well in which case just ask
them to work half an hour longer every
day okay you know it the the whole point
of capitalism is it's not actually a
process of efficiency optimization it's
a process of discovery it's it should be
pursued in a way much closer to
detective work and
investigation uh than uh as it has
become a kind of process of you know
basically cost cutting dressed up in
fantasy language
and you know as a perfectly enthusiastic
capitalist I see the discovery of new
forms of value exchange if employees
actually value flexibility and autonomy
uh more than they value money okay that
should be an opportunity in fact to
generate new value that you can reward
people in apart from in the else okay
um I think London without some sort of
George just escape from the strangle
hold of London property prices I think a
lot of these uh London knowledge
businesses uh effectively destroying the
lives of their young people if if I look
at our young staff uh after we pay them
you know every incremental pound we pay
them 40 40% will go in tax of what's
left over about 50% will go in uh
accommodation and transport costs
commuting costs and accommodation that's
an appallingly inefficient way to reward
people because you're really rewarding
London's buy toet landlords with every
pound you give them as much as you're
rewarding them and I I I don't I don't
think we're shrewd enough in spotting uh
you know in looking at efficiency in a
broad enough context what efficiency
means in rewarding people is you reward
people and a large amount of that money
goes to them and we've created a stupid
world where we demand people recent
graduates live in the most expensive
real estate on the planet and
effectively the capacity to actually
enrich people has more or less gone but
it's not helped by the fact that no
financially driven organization will
ever sit down and go what are the
reasons for paying some of our staff
more it's also not helped by politicians
either who s a lot of that red tape Rory
thanks so much for joining spectator
[Music]
TV